a change in leadership for UNLV football
thanks so much for joining us here at
noon I'm Heather Mills a UNLV Athletics
announcing that head coach Marcus Arroyo
is leaving the organization all this
coming as the students are continuing a
decades-old tradition of painting the
Fremont Cannon because of this weekend's
win Ron Futrell joining us live with the
details hi Ron
Heather a little surprising today the
back and forth we expected certainly the
cannon to get painted today but not the
firing of head coach Marcus Arroyo after
three seasons of UNLV packed against
some paint on my hand from shaking hands
with some of the players here a little
bit but let's take a look down here the
scene the crowd is sort of dissipating
at this point but earlier the Canon was
brought over by the players from the
Fertitta football complex to this
location here in front of the Student
Union at UNLV where let's see the
painting of the candy they didn't do a
real good job of painting the canyon
didn't the cannon didn't expect him to
but they did get the color right and
that's important to get it read they got
it because of the win over Reno
27-22 in Elysian Stadium on Saturday and
that of course is the trophy for the
battle of the state of Nevada here and
so the Canon now firmly painted red here
excited about that but the shocking news
Eric Harper announced that football
coach Marcus Arroyo two days after that
victory has been fired as Rebel football
coach
and this year we had success at the
beginning of the season but then
we we stalled out for six weeks and had
a very struggling game the other night
against UNR but you know just that full
body of work uh does not shoot a
trajectory of the program moving uh to
where we wanted to go and let's win
championships
well there were five and seven this year
overall for UNLV 7 and 23 is the record
for Marcus Arroyo in three seasons so
they felt that a change was needed now
the rebels have a shot at a bowl bid
surprisingly with five wins this year
they're one of the teams on the outside
but they've got to go deep the
requirement is you have to have six wins
to get a bowl bid but the rebels still
have a shot at a bowl bit I do want to
mention Marcus Arroyo's 2.3 million
dollar contract that he has left two
years on his contract that will still be
honored by the University of course so
he will be paid that money uh throughout
no matter who comes here as head coach
reporting live from UNLV Ron Futrell
eight Sports now wow okay so a little
bit surprising especially maybe after
that win the timing all right Ron thank
you so much we appreciate that